with 28 countries and all the goods and
services to choose from shopping online
should be a mecca for European consumers
but it's not an uneven playing field and
complex rules sees few SMEs trading
cross-border that's a flesh keep the
season in and marked for death upon
trabajo gananoque garnished identity
sheesh Cindy prices a window silly boy
fish burden our product the angeboten
there nice and early start the operation
we only fought at the plenary
Commissioner answer laid out the digital
roadmap the begging to stop price
discrimination and make Europe a
one-stop shop they can an all for one
and one for all approach really deliver
on giving better services prices and
access in line in different countries
you've got a different pieces of
legislation so much more can be done to
begin clarity the one-stop shop so you
only need to give the information once
when you're setting up in one country
other countries will then accept you
that's great but then there's issues to
do with can you enforce your copyright
in different countries do you face
different costs when trading in
different countries for many at the
debate the Commission strategy is a step
in the right direction but needs more
flesh on the bones if it's to lift off
you